alright guys so if you saw on the
schmoes know channel on Monday we
reviewed the 1989 Batman and as they
said in that video over on my channel
you're gonna get Batman Returns so here
we go with Batman Returns the only one
who can save this city
[Music]
is a creature of the night hello people
in Chris Stockman world we are the
schmoes if you don't know who we are I'm
Christian and I am mark and today we're
doing Batman Returns on Christmas
Channel we're very excited because this
is the second best Tim Burton Batman yes
the only was the second one that he ever
did only second one whatever was over
metal buddy that's get going all right
so what is Batman Returns
it's Batman returning from Tim Burton
anybody basically man you just analyzed
movies so well thank you this is Michael
Keaton coming back for a second round
and guess what there's two villains in
this one he's going up against the
penguin and against the very hot
Michelle Pfeiffer as Catwoman now a
Batman Returns I feel almost close to
the exact same way as the first I like
it just a teensy tad more and for a lot
of people that's a little different
because most people like the first one
more you got Michael Keaton back is
Batman you got Danny DeVito killing it
as the penguin I mean just thinking
about Danny DeVito as the penguin now
that is like the perfect idea for the
penguin he is this he is he kind of is
like a penguin in real life I mean poor
guy
you got Christopher Walken as Max
Schreck and Michelle Pfeiffer as
Catwoman she is so good as Catwoman and
Hathaway has big shoes to fill Halle
Berry was Catwoman what oh yeah she was
that was bad while she craves the
romance she can sink her claws into
[Music]
he plots a foul reign of destruction
this is where it started though with the
multiple villains mm-hmm you have
Catwoman played about Michelle Pfeiffer
you have Danny DeVito playing this thing
Oswald Cobblepot
this is now I know that I do not share
the popular opinion here I'm not a huge
fan of this movie I I'm not sure that's
the popular opinion in this movies that
people like it I I when I saw in the
theater I just had a weird feeling
afterwards yeah I've come to appreciate
it a little bit over time but the tone
of this movie is so dark and so kind of
different than the first one that I
think it turned a lot of people off yeah
you know it was is that the first movie
yes it had it was Tim Burton's Batman
but you still had Batman and there this
is all Tim Burton I mean it feels like a
Tim Burton movie the second starting
their circus is going on in the street
and you know the goofy stuff that's just
you know clowns and it just feels really
silly doesn't I don't feel like I'm in
Gotham anymore I feel like I'm gonna
twisted carnival as opposed to Gotham
and look at Robert wuhl was fine in
Batman I'm not gonna praise him beyond
words but there was no no real levity in
this movie it felt very dark and heavy
the whole time having said that it is a
Batman movie and I do enjoy watching
when it comes on TV especially because
the Danny Elfman score as in the first
one which we didn't mention and her view
is just phenomenal I think it's better
than the Hans Zimmer score and the
Christopher Nolan movies Tom's image
isn't Howard let's be easy on that but
yeah Danny Elfman's score is fantastic
and it really that is the one thing that
keeps it consistent throughout and this
movie penguin successfully turns Gotham
against Batman and that's one of the
reasons I like this would be a little
bit more because it made Batman the way
he was supposed to be he's kind of
supposed to be that outlaw vigilante
type you know not everyone's supposed to
be for sure like are you good or are you
bad he's on that line when he when he
was in Batman it was just all heroic and
yeah and everything but Batman Returns
kind of had that thing where the city
wasn't positive it gave the city some
down and it gave some strength to the
Batman character and I like that that
being said this is still Tim Burton
Batman and and what I mean by that is
it's not Batman it to me it's just it's
not really Batman yet it was still to
circusy and whimsical and everything
[Music]
there are some great performances in it
as well shelf life is great yes because
of the way she was able to because she
knew the tone of the movie and kind of
what she was working with she fit the
craziness of it all she had the only
really character arc in the whole film
yeah almost as good as Halle Berry's
Catwoman I'd say but even even that that
movie though like there was some silly
stuff though you know like what she's
licking herself like a cat and all this
kind of ridic not really because she
didn't become a cat she just got I mean
she got a 9 lot I don't know in my head
blows up thing little mark else became a
man that day and then he got Danny
DeVito is the penguin I enjoyed that
origin story a little bit I liked seeing
that he was this mistreated kid because
he was born with the penguin hands and
it just kind of it got a little tired
after a while I think was really silly
because I liked him much better was the
Laura yeah and we can't forget
Christopher Walken his Max Schreck he we
heard mister for Walken pee-wee Herman
has copper pots father and I can knees
in one scene still in the damn thing
you're in CARFAX commercials where the
first movie was a little bit too Joker
heavy I felt this movie balanced Batman
and the villains a little bit more than
the first one did Michelle Pfeiffer is
licking herself and everything and yeah
it's a little over the top but I don't
really mind she has this great
introduction to meeting Batman the
penguin she's flipping she's flipping
she's flipping she gets in front of them
it just goes you know the whole building
just blows up behind her great moment
[Music]
and also you don't stay consistent with
the lore of Batman he kills people in
this thing and then you know II the way
he teams over the silly romance that he
has with Selina Kyle and I just this
movie was all over the map for me I
don't really like it at all
I go 2 out of 5 shows it's tough for me
to watch all the way through I do enjoy
parts of but I can't get this movie to
three I'm sorry I'm gonna go like 2.8
out of five snows it's a Batman movie
love the score can't get it to a really
good score though it still has that that
Tim Burton Eve stuff you know like that
cheesy stuff going on though it just
wasn't Batman yet it also has a kind of
slow part in the middle where he's it
just seems like there was nothing really
going on except him and Michelle
Pfeiffer on a couch making out and
everything and it just kind of lasted
and I enjoyed the movie for the most
part it's just not quite Batman to me
I'm gonna give Batman Returns of B
samgrass okay the first one it's about
the same for me I just like it dad more
well it's a pleasure being here on Chris
Stockman's channel we hope you guys come
and like this place it's a nice it looks
a lot like our put comfy um now if you
guys want to come and see Batman Forever
then you got to check that out on our
show ways please the review of Batman
for everybody wants to see Batman
Forever our review on the other hand who
wouldn't want to watch that I'll kill my
was skinny it was thanks a lot smells is
nice having you on my channel if you
haven't checked them out before go over
there and check them out I thought the
first two films weren't quite Batman yet
Joel Schumacher sure took care of that
and as always guys you liked this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]